yong-chol nevertheless of course the
second most important vice president of
Brosky said here just a little bit
earlier that basically the currency has
also been seen as a project for the
European Union so we're gonna discuss
today of course the future of the euro
and how it will develop and evolve and
with the other countries joining the
Union and of course this is something
probably the first thing to discuss
would be the the reforms needed because
of course the holdest development
process is happening in very challenging
and very fast changing time so we're
gonna we gonna start with the reforms
and we're gonna start with the economic
and monetary union and I'm gonna go a
little bit back to go to the so-called
five presidents report that was done in
June 2015 and the presidents of five
European institutions the European
Commission the European Council the
European Central Bank the European
Parliament and the Euro group and they
published a vision for deepening for the
economic and monetary union of course
this has changed and developed and
developed lots of concrete proposals and
ideas of course ever since Commissioner
I'm gonna start here with the Euro group
will be discussing this afternoon some
of the crucial euro area reforms of
course dating back to their one vision
to you how do we how to take these
discussions if sometimes they might seem
quite detached from the day-to-day
reality of citizens well first of all
it's extraordinary the
wonderful place at twenty years after
and I feel as a young veteran because I
was there twenty years after one of the
survivors of this European Council when
we decided to launch the Euro and also
to pick up the first president of the
ECB to come I was then European affairs
minister and in the French delegation
and well that's true it's as well very
long already and still very young for
fighting was that
well when Valdez said a few minutes ago
that it was a political project he is
right so to me it meant a lot for us to
renounce to our national sovereignty on
currency we have absolutely a key step
and this meant a lot for example for
Germany and it was certainly the hope
then that we would be a capable of
deepening our Europe I must say
politically much more than we did and
after this you European summit I also
remember the Treaty of nice which was a
quite shy step forward but which
authorized us to move to route or did
not went and the failure of the
Constituent Treaty etc so I think the
the euro was really a political vision
and we've realized part of it not all of
it and if we are discussing today about
the reform of the euro zone it's because
we've created an incredibly powerful
monetary vehicle but we didn't have the
creation of a complete euro we need to
have there two feet obviously one is
stability and it's there and that's why
citizens in Europe feel that Europe euro
is protection for them and that's why
they're so much attached to the euro a
much more attached as a matter of fact
to the Europe than to Europe itself look
at what's happening in Italy for example
and there is a lack also an dislike of
another dimension of euro the capacity
to reduce inequality the capacity to
lead an economic and social policy and
we need to complete that and that's what
reforms are about and that's why I come
back to your questions it's not so
detached from everybody's life we live
in a world was yesterday in the g20 like
Nadia where you can see that illiberal
democracy is threatened
I came back just for one night in my
family in Paris and you see the Jillian
you see the Raisa populism everywhere
and you see that there is a need there
need to show that democracy as such and
liberal democracies especially can also
produce economic strength and social
justice and this is why we badly need to
complete the euro now because we need to
tackle the root causes of the present
crisis the connect crisis is over but
the legacies of the crisis are still
there the scars on our territories are
still there and we cannot only act with
the currency which provides us with
stability we need more and when we are
talking about banking Union it's in
order to protect the depositors when we
are talking about the exam it's about
the way to address better the debt
crisis when we are talking about the
eurozone budget it's about a capacity to
stabilize our economy in case of shocks
but also to reduce divergences inside
the eurozone because divergences is
certainly what creates a lot of social
concern and we have to face that that's
why I know that the topics seems I
wouldn't say artificial but a bit
abstract for other people it's very
concrete the day we have a substantial
eurozone budget I think we have
potentially powerful game-changer
politically - given the the change isn't
everything of course and the landscape
changing as you've mentioned we have the
situation with Italy we have all the
social movements of course were a couple
of months before the European election
with so many processes happening and so
many political changes as well happening
in Europe Minister what do you see as
the like the burning to keep burning
issues because of course all this
changing we have to understand that
probably the landscape now is the
fastest changing ever if we look at the
recent history of course
yes I was I was precisely I mean on the
basis of the previous question while
reflecting on the previous question and
I'll come to yours also I was thinking
that I have had contact with the euro in
three moments of my life first when we
were preparing the convergence plan of
Spain which I was in at the time in the
ministry which I'm now heading preparing
those documents and doing that you know
preparing the project from the
perspective of a national administration
and when the euro was introduced I
thought that it could only succeed on
the basis of trust between the people
when you do a currency change and you
see it in many countries you need people
to trust each other in the process of
this change otherwise it doesn't succeed
and at the time I thought it was really
an outstanding success the fact that we
were able to do it so seamlessly second
time in my life when I moved to
financial regulation in in 2010 and then
we started with a whole banking union
process which was at the time I was told
impossible it's not the only time in my
career that I've been told these
problems yes many times even now I'm
confronted with people telling me this
is impossible well impossible is only a
bit more difficult and difficult so so
we we launched this process which was
very ambitious which was always
obviously supported by the crisis
unfortunately you know was due to the
fact that people saw the need to
complete that part of the euro which had
not been included in the same we had
this very strong monetary union but we
were lucky lacking the banking Union the
fact that that this the financial sector
should also act as a stabilizing element
in this whole picture and now as
Minister for economy in my country I am
for the third time exposed to what's
going on and seeing that we have come a
long way in this 20 years we have come a
long way since 2010 we have built a
number of mechanisms which make the Euro
stronger I think we have to first
acknowledge that but there is still a
way to go the pieces of the puzzle are
there so it's a matter of political will
I fully agree with with Pierre that it's
you know the pieces that the technical
work is there it's a matter of deciding
whether or not to complete this this
phase
and then what's lacking also is that
trust that we had in the sense that
people do not quite understand what
we're discussing and this was your
question I keep saying you know oh yes
we succeeded we now have a backstop for
the srf this is not sexy this cannot be
explained to anybody you know people say
but what is this about now you're
protecting the banks again but who cares
about the people it's no surprise that
we have these populistic movements
coming up unfortunately no countries is
protected from that and that's why we
are so insistent on thinking also about
backstops for the people we want a
stabilization mechanism that allows to
incorporate for example unemployment
insurance as an element because that is
something that people understand we are
really insisting on Deposit Insurance as
an as a key element for the banking
union because people understand you know
deposit insurance and unemployment
insurance is something that citizens can
understand and frankly that I think a
mature democratic economic integration
process has to also integrate and take
care of let's go into consumer so we've
heard today as well that basically 74%
of the euro area citizens support the
single currency which is of course very
very high in the highest basically but a
lot has to be done still to maintain
this level of support and to make sure
that it's not going down probably going
up in the ideal scenario of course ms
media as an MEP who works on consumer
protection and of course a politician
from a from prospective eurozone member
I have to say they say about there are
we gonna go a little bit late into that
subject do you think that the benefits
of the Euro to consumers and travelers
are compelling enough for people to
understand the importance of it I think
was really interesting apart from the
74% of Europeans supporting the euro is
looking at who are the biggest
supporters of the euro and this is
actually the youth youngsters between 15
and 24 years old have more than 70
percent of support towards the Euro
they're in favor of the
who are those people one can call them
the razzle generation others can call
them the euro generally don't remember
the words I do not remember it they do
not remember 20 years back in in that
day what a significant milestone we
built into the history of our European
projects and for the years to come and
but it's important to see what they
actually admire and they know Europe of
no borders of seamless payments of
seamless travel so this is fantastic
news
but how to make sure that the trust they
have into the euro and we managed to
conceive and to build on it in order to
to even grow because what happens now is
that this part of Europeans do take the
euro for for granted in a way it has
been part of their world part of their
life as Europeans it has made their life
easier but as they take it for granted
they expect more from it so I think we
need to find ways to make sure that our
common currency is even better secured
and and more protected but also for the
citizens and I agree with the minister
it's these are very complex terms that
we work on within the European
institutions to explain to citizens the
way to do it is by them making feel
proud to use the Euro making them feel
proud to call themselves Europeans or
just by having a euro note or your euro
bank account or or a card that you that
you use your euro because it is a
tremendous achievements that makes lives
of consumers easiest most of those
people do shop online and they
absolutely love it if you look at
statistics that's one of the first
things that they say it's because they
know how much they pay compared to
countries and citizens that are outside
of the euro zone I currently work on one
of the reports on cross-border payments
where there are many consumers outside
of the eurozone not knowing how much
their credit
would cost or how much the payment they
would do will cost because of exchange
rates because of other costs being being
added so in order to preserve the trust
and maybe to continue growing which is a
bit difficult because we're at a point
where the euro has quite a lot of trust
despite if you look at national
institutions or national parliaments
across Europe the trust in those
institutions much lower where we need to
continue working is within countries
that are perhaps not members of the
eurozone yet because there the trust to
Euro is higher then you rose on for
example so I think people still cannot
really understand my getting into the
trap into the trap of taking things for
granted as we've heard every day with
the talk of course that it's very
dangerous when when people don't
sometimes remember how it could be
differently and then they do take it for
granted so therefore they don't feel
that passionate about supporting /
protecting it right so that's probably
the case with the young people when it
comes to the young Europeans correct
that's why I think to a very big extent
you need to show the benefits which I
think they can feel and that's why they
support it but in order to translate
that in the long run you need to try to
tell the story what happens from now
onwards and make them be part of
building that story themselves I'm much
more in favor of looking ahead of us
rather than behind us by learning what
we have build on but making sure that
this very critical mass of youngsters
out there are ready to build the new
chapter of the euro together with us
with passion with convictions ready to
do it with clear projects of knowing how
to do it and making them part feeling
that they own it
that way we can make them passionate
about it themselves let's not get the
perspective from businesses mr. carbone
but in your personal experiences
entrepreneur we sold the video so if you
go to the website here at 20 there is a
fantastic explainer and the benefits for
consumers for businesses of course I do
really want to hear your personal
entrepreneur the single currency in the
euro and the benefits and probably some
of the discoveries that it brought to
you sure so I think what you say is
exactly right first and foremost I think
the euro is it's probably one of the
most tangible signs of a true European
vertical integration and that's
something that is not it's not a
buzzword it's not something about
economic markets about European
technocrats it's something that you can
virtually feel in your hands and so
that's something for European consumers
and European citizens that sense apart
from just all the tech technical talk
about institutions and you know economic
markets second it obviously has huge
advantages for consumers if you just
think about travel we've have been
mentioning that if you think about
shopping I run a company that's selling
furniture online we sell furniture
online across Europe across South
America and what's so much exciting
customers about online shopping what is
it that customers driving to do online
shopping at all I think it's very simple
things to be honest it is all about a
large selection it's about great prices
it's about short delivery times and I
think I think actually the Euro if you
think about it the Euro really really
helps on each of those single items it
helps us to offer a huge selection more
than a hundred thousand products across
seven today several European markets
without having to officially adjust
prices it helps us to offer really
really good and customer prices because
we're able to to actually solve very
well with the euro and it also helps us
to have great delivery times because
actually all the the cross-border and
the customs problems fall away so it
helps to speed the whole thing up it
makes the the purchasing for customers
it makes cheaper they can have access to
a large assortment and they actually
have access to better prices so it's
fantastic one more question on this
because basically
you've just listed all the benefits and
undoubtedly here they are of course and
probably you have more if I ask you to
give me more we have the Eurogroup
meeting today we've just heard that
sometimes some of the reforms some of
the proposals reforms and initiatives in
the when it comes to the euro area to
some people to some consumers might seem
quite detached as commissioner said as
an entrepreneur with the Eurogroup
meeting might seem might seem only I was
not talking so much about consumers
wasn't but rather about citizen let me
get into the business with the Eurogroup
meeting today and also many proposals
and reforms on the table today and for
the future meetings of the Euro group as
well
what is it that you would want to see as
entrepreneur on the agenda of the Euro
group I think for businesses we have
huge examples we have huge advantages
that are pretty similar actually to the
advantages that are existing for
consumers so if you just think of you
know are selling buying furniture we're
selling it to consumers but we're buying
it first so when we buy furniture
actually price transparency plays a huge
role in a similar way FX rates play a
player to huge role so we're sourcing
today in probably 20 international
markets we're sourcing a lot within
Europe but we're also sourcing in Asia
we're all saw thing also sourcing in
South America so for us in a similar way
as for consumers it's super important to
have stability in FX rate so when we
need to move volumes and purchasing from
one market to another market we need to
move it from Asia to Europe within
Europe we need to move it to South
America that is costly that is bad for
business and so it is imperative for us
as a business that we remain with a very
strong international currency without
having so much fluctuations in our
business that is of major importance and
that's also why I think it's so
important to have a strong voice
internationally the Europe as the second
largest currency in the world and the
second most important currency in the
world just think for a second if we had
the kind of split into the German
Deutsche marks and the French franc and
so on and so forth we would be tiny in
terms of having a global voice for
businesses in the same way as for
citizens and for consumers this is a
huge advantage we can discuss a lot
about that and I fully agree with that
have been said about the advantages for
consumers for the economy for business
etc the problem is that we must not have
a passive acceptation of the euro
because today why did the Greeks support
the euro at 75% of the population in
such a terrible time as the Greek crisis
why do the Italians support the Euro at
64% in a time where obviously there is a
populist wave in the country and rather
nationalists because people perceive
spontaneously that going back to the
past
going back to national currencies would
create a lot of damage to the economy
and this is of course the strength but
you cannot live forever if you think
about the next 20 years with only it
would be worst if it was different you
need to give a new sense a new vision
and also a new social utility to the
euro and this is what we need to address
in the eurozone reform would first
answer to your last remark with a little
bit of patience the coming the
Commission is going to deliver
communication on Wednesday about the
international of the euro and obviously
we need to strengthen that for the
business and especially also to address
the unforeseen and undesirable
consequences of unilateral actions as we
might have seen in the recent period but
if I move to the your group of this
afternoon it would be a I think quite
long meeting Nadia and quite difficult
one after a process which has been at
the same time challenging interesting
and also let's say disappointing what
can we expect I would say the least
would be an agreement YES on the
single resolution fund this is quite
technical but that also means that we
have now a very strong protection for a
banking sector and our banking sector
finally are the people behind it but we
need to complete that wouldn't be
satisfied if it was the only result on
the field of banking Union I was also
there in the beginning of the process in
2012-2013 and when we design banking
Union Abbas then finance minister of my
country the idea was to have supervision
we have it resolution we are going to
complete it but also to to address the
issue of depositors and this is why the
process of Eadie's must be kept alive
more than that we need to have now a
political process in order to launch
through it is I know that there are
reactances around the table and thinking
especially about Germany but well it's
afternoon I hope this is unlocked if
it's not it's a disappointment the
second issue is about the ESM the
European Stability Mechanism well I
think that basically we've done the job
to Commission on ESM we now have a
common approach we will also avoid
overlapping and that will be good we
will have a strengthening of the ESM but
the true progress for the exam will be
the day when it's incorporated inside
the new institutions and so also
democracy controlled by the European
Parliament as must be the whole
functioning of your group and I will add
a third point and as a three musketeers
there are three plus one the third point
is about eurozone budget as I said in my
introductory remarks this is the key we
need to have a eurozone budget in order
to address some imbalances to reduce
divergences to be a capable of facing
shocks and we need there to have the
launching of a process if this is not
the case then we will have a technical
package which will be interesting but we
won't have a true eurozone Arif
process and I hope that the ministers in
the new group will be capable to deliver
that and to address it to the eurozone
summit so that by the end of the year we
can say six months before the European
elections it would be then four months
five months we have something ambitious
we are conscious that the Euro needs to
enter into a new phase we have seized
the window of opportunity that was
opened 18 months ago there was a lot one
four years ago but well it was not
seized and so let's do that
and as I said three plus one there is a
referent which is no more in the room
but for me need to be reintroduced in
the room which is democracy I don't see
the future of Euro without a democratic
governance I think the way we manage
with the euro is not satisfying a few
years ago did he even dice Bloomberg
well I thought it and I didn't think it
I I talked about a Democratic scandal I
didn't mean that the decisions we were
taking were scandalous generally there
are welcomed rated but the fact that you
can have 23 people in a room deciding of
the fate of millions of others without
any kind of democratic control this is
not viable in the long run it's not
impossible it's not possible societies
evolve more and more transparency more
and more accountability and the euro is
something very special because it's
absolutely informal the Euro group
without any control we need to have
control people want to take back control
and if we don't want them to take back
control nationally we need to give them
the chance to take back control at the
European level and this is why the ideas
which were raised and I did that as
early as 2013 of a eurozone Minister of
Finance and control by a parliament
some say a eurozone parliament I say
simply the European Parliament these
ideas must not be forgotten they are no
more on the table but they must come
back and if they don't come back we will
have back
from the citizens Minister I have three
reflections to add of course I agree
fully with what he has just said but
three three reflections one of them is
that we have learned through the crisis
but we we should have known it before
but now we have learned the hard way
that we are on the same boat so whatever
happens in one country is going to have
an impact on the stability of all of
these countries in the eurozone and
beyond from this point of view I think
that the the aim must be that the
eurozone is a source of stability and
not of instability if citizens don't
think that the euro is going to bring a
better future you know sooner or later
they're going to question the process so
all the agreements that we take tonight
should be seen in this perspective of
making the euro zone stronger providing
stability to all the members a second
reflection in in this regard is
precisely this element that that PM was
mentioning that in the long run or as a
vision as an objective one has to think
of a fully integrated economic and
fiscal policy if we want to have an
economic and monetary union but I think
in this field as is the case with
everything in Europe actually we make
progress by small steps where you make
this small step and only after you have
made it you realize well I'm not turning
back and then what you were discussing
was going very much in this direction I
think we have to make it through reality
that people everyday feel that this is
positive for them more than giving them
a vision which is maybe not going to be
attainable that's why I think in in this
area of the eurozone deepening the
approach of Spain is one of strong
ambition but also pragmatism in the
sense of we're not going to achieve
everything tonight you know I really
want to be very we are not going to
achieve I mean I've fully fledged 80s
and a fully fledged budget and a fully
fledged this is a this is a vision for
the future we're going step by step we
can make important steps now and in
December and and the fact that we are
only moving step by step should not be
seen
as a disappointment or as a lack of
success I want to emphasize this point
because I don't know the press in in
France the power or the prince here in
the Brazos bubble but in my country
every time it's alright so disappointing
because we're not achieving a hundred
percent but we have to move step by step
and in the in the area of the euro it's
the real advantages that people feel
that are going to reinforce the project
and ask people you know and people will
want to go deeper and and to go further
that would be that those would be my my
two key reflections in to what what VI
was saying he's been also cited the
previous session that some of those
proposals and the reforms we just now
discussing they had they basically
emerged up to the crisis and of course
there was this urgent ambition and it
had to be something just had to be done
fast as fast as possible and of course
probably nobody absolutely nobody wants
that but in some cases how to while
taking it step by step of course and
while taking it carefully and accurately
how still to achieve without of course
we don't need another crisis to move
faster on that and to have this urge and
to make everybody feel the same way
about the need to continue with the
reforms this is the main message I keep
sending in all the meetings is to me
this would be a failure you know that we
only wake up in the next crisis because
what we saw in the crisis was that many
of these elements we we should have seen
them coming we should have seen these
weaknesses and okay there was no desire
to address them for whatever reason this
is the message that we keep sending to
everybody around us is now that we have
gone through this process once let's not
repeat it twice you know let's try to
build and strengthen the house while the
sun is shining instead of waiting for
the rain to come to realise that the
roof was not perfectly you know
protected about crisis maybe a few
reflections first we got the last crisis
and we have the lessons of the crisis
which are there and the legacies of the
crisis and so we must not think that
we've done everything that we had to do
there are still legacies
and there are still problems to address
second we must always prepare for the
next crisis I don't know when it is
coming and the letter but the better but
well of course we need to be prepared
and this is why the lessons of the
crisis again have to be taken and third
I think we are in a crisis we are no
more in an economic crisis but we're in
a political crisis we are in social
crisis and this crisis this political
crisis is probably the worst that the
you ever endued because this time we
have an existential crisis it is the
existence of Europe and euro which is in
question and this is why I fully agree
with you Nadia
we can do nothing else than work step by
step that's the way Europe is we are a
very special institutional framework
with institutions which are from the
chemistry method which are in a way
Federalist and also intergovernmentalism
and we need to act by consensus and it's
very difficult to convince all our
Member States and we must understand
that we must respect that because they
are different they are their own culture
etc etc so I do agree but the problem is
the size of the steps and at one moment
you can be disappointed let's be clear
to me I'm not anticipating the next
meeting but if we have just a technical
agreement on srf without a process on
Eadie's I'm not satisfied on ESM if the
perspective of having TSM once inside
the European institutions is not on the
table and disappointed and if we have
nothing I cannot imagine that on your
group budget I think that we have made a
very small step and of course step by
step yes but I think for the time being
we need to make some big steps forward
which will open the way to more
ambitious approaches if it's not the
case we are just walking slowly and
young people need to walk fast and the
euro is young
it must not consider itself as in its
last age so this is why step-by-step yes
but quite some vigorous steps please I
say that to ministers and to heads of
state and government in two weeks to
come miss Meza with the consequences of
course of the crisis just mentioned by
Minister by the Commissioner we are a
couple of month before the European
election and we know about all the
movements sometimes anti-european
movements and the feelings the
skepticism feeling yet you are coming
from the country which is basically the
latest member states to have embarked on
the path of the Euro adoption how about
the feeling there from that perspective
what was a bulgarian mep i first have to
say that Bulgaria's aspiration to
joining the eurozone is first of an
integration thing it's a similar case
with with the Schengen case we do want
to continue our integration within the
you and move towards the center in order
to make sure that any sort of various
speeds scenarios that sometimes are
being presented do not affect us we see
and I think especially prior to the EU
elections it's very important the way we
see the euro we see it as a success
story as our common currency that has
managed to unite us it's a sign of
solidarity and a process that has to
continue and speaking of ambitious steps
perhaps after a number of challenges
including brexit when for the first time
a country would like to to leave Europe
we need to show that some of those very
existential projects or clubs if we want
to call them they're open for member
states that are willing to be part of
this integration and are committed to do
the necessary in terms of reforms in
terms of controls in terms of being a
part of
where you need to play by the rules and
I think it's it's it's a very good and
clear message also for the other
countries that have shown signs that
they want to be part of the eurozone
such as Croatia and Romania in the long
run and very briefly mr. Carbone the
business opportunities of the countries
in the member states that are willing to
join of course not 20 Bulgaria's you
just said what are the business
opportunities that you see in this case
I absolutely welcome this again you know
it's one of the largest free markets it
needs to be had had to had integrated
with the European single market and if
we ever from a business perspective if
we ever want to be head-to-head with the
United States and China in terms of you
know international tech champions you
know there's been a lot of discussion
going on that all the tech champions
that have been emerging over the last 20
30 years are actually located either in
the United States and China 90% of the
worlds were of the world's a venture
capital is going into the United States
in China and if this ever needs to be if
this ever should be a European success
it will only be through a further
European integration and a very strong
euro so from a business perspective I
can I can only highly recommend you know
if criteria are met or further
integration you know including for other
countries such as Croatia and Bulgaria
along with the proposed proposed actions
that are being you know discussed as we
speak one thing I want to come back to
is it's a bit a bit of a macro spirit
perspective but the minister was
mentioning stability as a key factor I
think this cannot be underestimated
stability is at the heart of it and we
we live in a time that's basically
politically and economically been shaken
up where you know the post-war
post-world War certainties of
multilateralism are basically breaking
apart and one person story my my father
just turned 75 on Saturday and he gave a
bit of a speech and he said that he was
most thankful that out of those 75 years
73 years he's been remarkably able to
live in peace
and at the heart of it I think that the
euro is as a project alongside the
European integration of war and peace
and if we think about discussing future
steps and if you think about you know
explaining those future steps to the
public let's not get too much lost into
the details as important as they may be
but let's think of explaining what
Europe and the euro are truly about and
I think that's one of the points I
wanted to highlight thank you very much
we're now going to take the questions
from the audience
please raise your hand we have please
yeah we go coming through the Bell
good morning my name is Javier Goff
i member spanish member of Economic and
Social Committee after here this morning
the species of the European leaders I am
somewhat disappointed first I have not
listened what would really be necessary
to implement to convert the eurozone in
an optimal monetary zone by example with
a common tax policy or less harmonized
tax policy and second I have not
listened anything about the relation
between the very negative social and
political consequences of the crisis and
European Union institutions for the
management of the price in Spain
yesterday far-right party box entry is
only in the region and at regional
Parliament in Andalusia now in Spain is
closure of Europe also in this aspect I
think really that it would be necessary
to think more about what hat we do but
thank you very much for your question
and this is exactly what we discussed in
the second part of our panel about the
consequences and of course with the news
today from Andalusia obviously do you
want to add something on the on the
consequences on the social situation and
the way this is basically with tackle to
two remarks first of all I think that
precisely maybe I was not clear enough
when I was referring to in the long run
we need to have a fully integrated
economic and fiscal policy as a second
limb of this monetary policy I was
precisely reflecting this optimal
monetary areas and and eventually where
we need to go to and this ambitious plan
so I was precisely referring to that now
on the on the issue of
ilysm and nationalism I don't think that
the there is one cause to eat or there
is one single factor that leads to it
and and and maybe fortunately because
the pressure would be awful I don't
think it depends on us reaching an
agreement tonight you know this
impression goes yeah it really is a bit
that pressure I think that in itself but
but obviously the euro crisis has as I
said this was my first remark was has
diminished trust in general on the
multilateral process we were discussing
it in the two in the g20 quite intensely
over the weekend in the in the political
system at national at European level and
I think that indeed reinforcing the
elements which allows citizens to see
what is in for them is certainly a very
important factor if we want to continue
as I think everybody in this room does
to continue creating this prosperity
through the further deepening and
integration of our economies and and our
peoples from the political point of view
to what won't react what you said about
enlargement of the euro zone
just to recall that in the white paper
of the European Commission
we gave open the way to eurozone
including all Member States of the EU
except one
we know Denmark which has all chosen to
have an opt-out that doesn't mean that
is mandatory but that we must organise
your zone so that it can welcome all the
candidates and I also know that arg area
is already a candidate what needs to be
done is first that the country needs to
prepare itself because we need to
succeed when a country enters and
prepared in the euro zone it can be a
problem both for itself and for the
eurozone but well the the the the road
is opened and we must collectively
prepare for a currency which is the
currency of the whole Union when I'm
sure that once Denmark will join but
that's I wouldn't say it's off the
record because they if somebody's Danish
here I know that I'm
going to have a great success but I see
that for an example and then mark is
interested in the banking Union when
you're interested in banking Union well
one way you'll have to consider the rest
of the offer as a package but to come to
the remark there first what is Europe I
know that for some who tried to find a
scapegoat
Europe is Brussels it's the bubble and
especially it's the Commission and I can
see that at several levels in in several
countries but Europe is not the bubble
Europe is not Brussels Europe is all
European citizens or European
governments all of us and so there is a
collective responsibility there and the
question is not did Europe do too much
but what didn't Europe do which was
necessary and so I think this is the
point on which we must reflect
collectively confronting this national
populist
threat nationalist populist threat that
we have now to face the second thing is
if I was asked is there one thing that
was not done correctly I would say yes
inequalities when I see the lessons of
the quest crisis because it's the
inequalities which create this sense of
resentment frustration lack of identity
and not to be respected and also then a
fear of migrants xenophobia it's not the
only cause but it's one of the root
causes of nationalism and populism and
if that's what we have done then that's
what we must now tackle and this is
again one of the reasons why when we
discuss about the eurozone but this is
not that abstract it's about reducing
divergences in
in Europe and in eurozone because if
eurozone is not only about convergence
but only about stability then at one
stage it will disappoint did it already
happen no because people still trust D
euro but they want more from us the
policymakers and this is why again I say
step by step yes but let's accelerate
the walk and I'm not insisting too much
because I don't want to be heavy but
still there is some pressure and the
pressure is is there it's the pressure
of the people I'm just a quick reaction
because I fully agree with what the
commissioner said I think we a country
before entering the eurozone has to be
fully prepared and that's why my own
country has been working already since
the past couple of months in a road map
together with the European institutions
to make sure that the entry into erm -
happens over the course of the next
couple of months but what I want to pick
from what you said further is in order
for us to be a credible story for the
Euro we need to make sure that there is
ownership from each and every one of us
because just like Europe starts with
each and every one of us when we want to
aspire to a new project it has to start
also from the cities so if in a member
state that is aspired to join the
eurozone there is not enough
understanding about what the euro is and
what the benefits of the euro are
political support is necessary reforms
are necessary but the ownership of this
sort of aspiration and projects comes
from the citizens themselves so let's
make sure that the benefits of the euro
and the eurozone are better known to the
European citizens that are not part or
some of them that are part and perhaps
not so happy and do not support it and
it's a collective I think effort that
has to be done thank you we're gonna go
we're gonna move two more questions here
thank you Carlo Segovia in Spanish all
as well for the Spanish daily newspaper
Monde I have I think it's a follow-up
question for the commissioner and the
for the Spanish Minister how to convince
the central and northern countries to
complete the banking union with this
growing population in Italy of course
and as we say in Andalusia in the
original elections how to fight the
mistrust with this growing population
how to convince the countries
multi-billion dollars question yes there
are two questions the first one is must
all the countries be concerned and
convinced I'm sure they do if I look at
what we've done during the crisis I
would say there are two sides of the
coin
the first one is risk reduction and the
other side is risk sharing on risk
production we've done a lot the
stability and growth pact I would say
basically is about it the first steps of
the banking Union are about it we need
also to our right balance between risk
reduction and risk sharing and this is
why it is is so important and I know
just like Nadia that we are not going to
complete the full process today but we
need to open the way for it when those
who were in the room and I was in the
room decided to launch the banking union
it was a three pillar construction
supervision resolution and Deposit
Insurance Scheme we must not forget the
third pillar Pietist is this pillar
which is I think what the people really
expect and remember for example the
crisis on Cyprus and the second question
is how to convince well I think that
everybody must be conscious of what's
happening in Europe today we have
elections in six months from now they
are the most important and the most
difficult and even the most dangerous
we were faced and for that for Europeans
need to be offensive they need to really
show a leadership optimism and ambition
and for that everybody needs to be on
board and I think it would be an
illusion if some of the citizens because
they are more protected today than the
others think that there is a
one-size-fits-all model which is their
own no it's about solidarity the
interest of the richer countries in
Europe and I'm not naming this one or
that one but everybody here can see that
I'm talking about some countries their
interest is that their neighbors are in
a better position and this is about
solidarity solidarity is something that
protects you before because when your
neighbor is getting better in a European
construction and in a single currency
you get better and if ultimately your
neighbor doesn't go well you don't go
well we're gonna take the final question
here I'm so sorry Chavez grant from the
Center for European reform in the first
panel we talked about the de loire
report one of the things that the law
report asked for was a common fiscal
position for the European Union that got
watered down in the ena in the
Maastricht Treaty we did with its crude
three percent budget rule so my question
to the panel is as I'm sure many of us
would agree to have a more successful
eurozone one needs a common fiscal
stance for the European Union I need
some sort of counter cycle physical
mechanism the Germans don't like that
how can we persuade Germans and other
North Europeans to accept a common
fiscal position instead of just looking
at the individual fiscal positions of
each individual member state yes well we
have gone somewhat to a certain extent
in this direction in the sense that now
we are looking more at the fiscal stance
of the eurozone and not only the
individual member states I think there's
still a long way to go in terms of
looking at the imbalances and if I may
not only looking at imbalances in one
direction but in all directions I mean
to say it's not only a deficit that can
be problematic in in a certain
situation but we are going in that
direction I mean we I think that the
progress in that in that sense is going
in parallel to the other elements
although one would say that indeed we
have advanced much more faster talking
about decisive steps now the in the area
of banking we have made much clearer
progress and in the area of fiscal
integration and and I fully agree with
what pierre was saying that we need we
will not agree everything tonight but we
absolutely need to set the the scene for
where we are heading towards because and
that this is a final thing but i want to
say is that one area where people are
going to be very annoyed is if they
transfer part of the sovereignty and
part of the decision-making process to
the european level but then the
consequences remain at the national
level and that is why we need the
Deposit Insurance to be integrated
because it cannot be that we have a
single supervisory mechanism that we
have a single resolution mechanism but
if there are consequences on the fiscal
side I mean the eddies and the rest of
it those would be borne by the national
level you know you have to have
parallelism of what is moved and what is
decided and where the consequences are
born and taken at the end of the day
that I think is very important if we
want to avoid a further surge of
populism going forward and then note I'm
so sorry but I'm afraid we have run out
of time I know we have more questions
from the audience I do have more
questions here I'm sure you have so much
more to say thank you very much for this
conversation and for this panel thank
you
[Applause]
please please we have we're not done yet
yes we have please we have concluding
remarks from our kabuki director-general
for economic and financial affairs
European Commission the floor is yours
thank you very much it was a great event
the great start actually over a year
where we are going to have many other
events of this sort I mean you harm you
must have perceived that celebration yes
but also or no complacency I mean we
have a journey to do we are going to
cross the river by touching the stones
but we have to see the stones and
sometimes as the the Commissioner
mentioned that we had to jump from one
stone to another taking a a bit of a
leap I mean for those like me and I see
several several good friends in the in
the room here who were in the kitchen
since the beginning I mean this is a
great it's a great achievement and
actually if you think about the crisis
we have gone through I remember
sometimes during the euro area crisis we
had the CNN live coverage like when you
have you know a kidnapping that you have
the coverage anything so the Euro would
not achieve would not get to the next
morning actually a huge mistake that was
made by the by the markets also design
by observers was not to sufficiently
estimate the kind of political
commitment that at the end of the day
was was there several statistics were
mentioned this morning from
Eurobarometer
basically 64% thinking that the euro is
good for your country
75% thing that the euro is good for the
EU as a whole so it means that maybe
others they benefit more than than
Europe your country I think there were
two other statistical women we should be
no mention which I think they indicate
the sense of direction the first one was
that the question to the question of
whether euro the Euro strengthened the
sense of belonging and European living
it's only a quarter who says so
so 25% to say yes I feed the Europe
strengthen my feeling as a European and
then the other the other statistic is
that asked whether one should have more
policy coordination so more togetherness
then 70 percent says yes we should so
probably if you put together all this
you get the sense that more passion
representing said that at the beginning
plus more policy coordination a more
common I think common strategy is the
way to build to let's say to bridge the
gap between
euro for yourself euro for the you and
also to increase the sense of of
togetherness I mean 20 years for
currency is is a very short period I
mean I was looking this morning at the
US if you if you look at the u.s. 7076
regulation of Independence the first
bank of the US was in 1791 it took till
1917 to have the first small budget at
the same at the federal level and until
1932 for the budget at the at the
federal level in the u.s. to play some
counter cyclical so stabilization
function
and the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation so the equivalent of eddie's
was in 1934 now we should not wait so
long
Europe the sense of they say history and
and the fact that you know relinquishing
sovereignty at the national level and
having the sense that you get back
sovereignty at the European level it is
hard it is politically difficult that's
why the discussion today the Eurogroup
is so important that's why in
mid-december when the euro area summit
will convene I will have to make
decisive steps but the journey will
still be long in from in front of us but
I think we are here determined to do so
and as you have to say looking at Pierre
as European Commission I always think
the European Commission's what does
differentiate us visibly the rest the
government's international tour this I
think myself thinking as an economist we
have a lower discount rate it means
having lower discount rate what does it
mean it means you have a longer time
horizon compared to getting to the next
to the next election so I think we are
going to insist them and and continue in
yes feeling the stones but that champing
sometimes and definitely seeing that we
get to have to to get to the other side
of the river so this is my final award I
would like to thank my team Philip Todd
and and a nice team communication team
for helping organising this has been a
very good very good event obviously
thanking all the speakers bepah 17 in
the first place who gave the lot to our
[Music]
to our day and the two panelists and you
you all thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
you